between Taylor Swift's grand opening
and Missy Elliott's meaningful speech
y'all lot of beats to the heart
this year's MTV Video Music Awards were
one for the books but it was all the
stuff that happened when the cameras
weren't rolling that really had people
talking now here's the see now we are
counting down nine things you didn't see
on TV starting with this when Taylor hit
the stage to perform her hits you need
to calm down and love her and I
witnessed lzt that Camilla Kibeho stood
up and danced her ass off in the
celebrity section next up some serious
fangirling over queer eyes Jonathan
Vanessa Taylor went nuts after jvn
walked out to present an award now you
might remember he starred in her you
need to calm down music video and he
also awarded the song the video for good
award
[Applause]
but swifty wasn't the only one to lose
her mind over jonathan backstage sophie
turner gushed over meeting the gay of
thrones creator - can you believe number
7 on our list a few sweet moments
between Caitlyn Carter and Miley Cyrus
[Music]
moments before Miley hit the stage to
perform her new single slide away
cameras showed the two backstage and I
witnessed lzt that the two were seen
holding hands at one point Kaitlyn even
put her hand on Miley's but the
eyewitness added that they quote looked
very much like a couple then there's
this TV magic the beginning of Missy
Elliott's video Vanguard performance was
taped before segwaying into the live
ending everyone stayed on their feet for
Missy's performance the entire time and
a Missy chant broke out with all the
celebs in the audience joining in Missy
Missy Missy oh and if you were wondering
about cardi B's giggle onstage mhm
apparently someone loudly yelled cardi
which cracked her up
[Music]
Tayler stayed on her feet for Shawn
Mendes and Camilla caballos racy
performance she didn't even take a seat
until they were totally off the stage
bonus fact coming at ya Shawn and
Camilla have both opened up her tailor
on tour as for the rumored couple the
two entered the arena together and sat
super close we are talking clothes
people like he had his arm around her
shoulders and even played with her hair
swooned but no one had more fun than
bebe Rexha and Elizabeth the two jammed
out to almost every single performance
we can always count on the VMAs to get
us talking and we'll always be right
here to give you all the tea until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Applause]
you
[Music]